hey everybody what a day
another day another erratic donald trump
press conference
over the last couple of days donald
trump uh
interviewed by axios jonathan swann and
that went
very very poorly just lost a nut look at
that
um went very very poorly and
i guess in order to redeem himself he
tried to do an interview on fox and
friends this morning and it went almost
as poorly
like given that it was meant to be a
soft softball interview it went almost
as poorly and i have a few different
clips from it
um that we might look at a little bit
later but i do want to first issue a
very important disclaimer
we will never be anti yosemite
on this channel okay it will never
happen remember this from yesterday the
i
this is my commitment to you anti
yosemites
will never be allowed here take a listen
when their eyes widen in amazement
as old faithful bursts into the sky
when they gaze upon your semites your
seminites
we are not going to be against yosemite
norio semonites on this channel
that's my commitment to you and i expect
you to absolutely
hold me to it um what else do we have
today we actually have some extremely
notable
internet superstars who have been
stopping by the streams lately
we have today again we are graced by
the incomparable grand master benjamin
feingold over on twitch yesterday
benjamin feingold was here so was uh
philip defranco
who um we who is it was really him he
sent a super
chat yesterday and he gifted some subs
as well
so we have a lot a lot a lot of
uh of notable and extremely respected
people coming by
um which is interesting nonetheless and
i think you know what i think has really
polarized the twitch and youtube
community
is this unfortunate uh
shot across the bow from sam cedar that
happened yesterday you know i think
sam was trying to rally the troops to
get him to a million youtube subscribers
before me
and you know to some degree i think it
fired up his supporters
um but it has also brought
all sorts of people out of the woodwork
on my end
and i don't know that that was really
what sam intended and it's getting very
very ugly i've actually hired celebrity
lawyer mark
garagos to represent me i don't know why
i need representation but i just feel
like when sam cedar shoots
across your bow you hire mark mark
garagos
and it almost made me think i should
hire that guy that defended george
zimmerman mark o'mara because i'm going
to need to bring out the big guns here
i'm expecting something to get very very
ugly now
i don't want to say more about that
because soon we may be taking legal
action
and if you don't know anything about
what i'm talking about good
good but i will have a detailed clip
publishing tonight at i think 9 pm
eastern time
or 10 30 pm eastern time so that'll be
later today
what else do i have for you guys today
um as we wait
the united states likely tomorrow will
hit five million cumulative coronavirus
cases that's a tragic number this is
where
you know how trump says we're last which
makes us first this is an instance where
we are first which makes us
very very much dead last another 43 000
cases today
now i really need everybody to
understand this
florida stopped testing on thursday
because of the hurricane
the hurricane of course is which donald
trump
really struggles to say but it's isaias
and um
florida stopped testing on thursday and
they were scheduled to resume today
so when we see florida with only 5 400
new cases where
they were having 10 12 14 000 they it's
not a conspiracy they announced
we are not testing until the hurricane
passes california yesterday announced
that they had been under reporting cases
so
at minimum florida and and california
without getting conspiratorial
just going by what they've said are
under reporting cases and of course
yesterday we again had
um close to 1400 cases it's very bad
georgia school districts one has 260
people exposed or tested positive
because of
um crowding in georgia schools a kid who
took
pictures of the crowding in georgia and
published them to social media
instead of being thanked by the school
district he was suspended
can you imagine um so it's it's getting
it's getting very very bad
and we're going to be talking about that
just keep an eye on okay we're not live
yet we already did yosemite's
update on the projections from the
standpoint of youtube subscriptions
thanks to you amazing people we have
moved up the expected date on which we
will hit a million subscribers
could have sworn that light just blinked
by three weeks uh
as of last week we weren't expecting to
hit a million until january 9th thanks
to you guys it has been pushed up to
december 16th
only 30 43 days to go my goal is
november 3rd election day
i would like to hit a million
subscribers so that's all going very
very well
um my discussions about churning ideas
and french pressing ideas
it made it onto the dave rubin subreddit
david pakman is churning and
hydraulically pressing
ideas this i i love that this made it
over there and i think it's somebody
who's probably watching right now
remember this from yesterday
i mean listen there's a cheap way to
dramatically accelerate my following
which is to have some political
awakening where i
find truth and see the light and
denounce everything
right we're not going to do that okay
if i can't get to a million subscribers
based on doing what i actually believe
wink wink um then i'm not gonna get to a
million subscribers and that's it
that's it i'm churning ideas here i'm
french pressing ideas
i am uh you know extracting ideas very
powerfully like an espresso machine
uh i'm sauteing ideas and all of these
other things
uh so and and they are going to be my
ideas i'm not gonna do
you know we know about grifting we know
about grifting very powerfully
exactly so i really loved seeing that
over on the
dave rubin subreddit which it seems like
he completely lost control of a
subreddit the few times i've gone over
there it seems people hate him on his
own
subreddit which is crazy we are going to
be distilling ideas i will be using
double osmosis a reverse is it double or
reverse uh
reverse or double osmosis double reverse
even triple reverse i might do with
ideas and it's going to be great
we are already almost at a level 4 hype
train on twitch which is crazy
brazing ideas like a like a hanukkah
brisket absolutely
let me do a couple of super chats
because they are coming in very fast and
furious and i don't want to fall
behind um what did i have for lunch
i actually had tom yum soup one of my
favorite soups if you had to tell if you
came to me and you said david
gunn to your head you've got to rank
your top five soups
um up with matzo ball soup
and up with um what are what other are
my favorite soups
i mean listen matza ball soup and tom
yum are certainly some of my favorite
soups hot and sour
so hot and sour tom yum and matzo ball
soup are probably my three favorite
soups
um and maybe chicken noodle as well
but yeah i had my uh i had my tom yum
soup
chakuseki says can we petition the space
force to launch donald trump into the
sun so he can harvest all the raw
solar plasma for the u.s thanks david
that's an idea
stewart says hey pac daddy what are your
thoughts on trump encouraging mail-in
ballots in florida specifically
i have a broad and long clip about that
that's going to be publishing to youtube
today so i don't i try to avoid
duplicative content on the streams
darkchip says will we see a plasma party
soon i think so
maestro cam says trump just tweeted an
obama gate video on twitter okay
maybe we'll look at that a little later
um
ryan nowicki says bush signed directive
51 in 2007 it gives broad emergency
powers to potus
have you read about it please give your
thoughts soon if not i've read about it
a little but not enough to comment
unknown prodigy says wait sam cedar was
serious is this a joke
the rift that has um plagued the
progressive media community as a result
of sam cedar taking the unprecedented
step of accusing me of using bots to
boost
my subscriber numbers has uh
divided the it's it's very very real
it's very real and i'm kidding
i it's it's not real but it's i it's
funny
zachary foster says andy slavitt said
last night on cnn that the next
important step is fauci and others to
reassure skeptics of the vaccine
released by the trump administration
yeah i actually was i'm preparing i
actually do prepare material for my show
i do
try to get things right and i'm
preparing a segment friday about
what percentage of the population do i
expect not to get the vaccine
a poll from may 27th and another from
june 30th both said half the country
don't plan on getting the coronavirus
vaccine
we will not have heard immunity if
that's the case and i'm going to go into
detail about that on friday
let me say a few twitch thank yous
sahira
has subscribed with prime bit 101 and
boy meets mini
have cheered spudnik19 has gifted
10 subscriptions grand master benjamin
feingold has sent a cheer
erica has subscribed so has tysis
and coyle twitch bot
uh okay and that's it that's what's
going
on and we do have a level four hype
train going on
um a few people to thank for signing up
on my website
sean mcintyrf mcinturf
is new member number one today also
michael zakaria
is number two nancy joe chatham
chatham like chatham massachusetts on
cape cod is number three jacob herbert
you are new member number four
and i think that's it yeah that's
everybody very exciting
uh i am expecting donald trump to take
questions today
okay people i i'm getting this question
lately because of all these polls that
say biden's up 10
biden's up 12 bidens of 15. the idea is
what is trump's path to victory you
don't have to go
crazy to think about trump's path to
victory the path to victory is the
following first and foremost
if a poll says biden is up 10 and the
margin of error is 3.5
that could mean biden is really only up
three and we
know that you can win the popular vote
by 2.2 like hillary did in 2016 and
still lose
so in other words if you believe the
polls if you look at a poll that says
biden plus 10
and you believe it is accurate today
with a 3.5 margin of error that could
mean
biden is three and a half lower trump is
three and a half higher
10 is really a three-point lead 2.2
could mean trump wins again with small
margins in wisconsin pennsylvania et
cetera
which means the real situation even
believing the polls
could be that if trump can pick up one
point between now and november he can
win
so you don't need to go like into
conspiratorial
stuff or october surprises or anything
it could be
within the margin of error trump might
only be down three right now
and if a vaccine starts uh yes i know it
goes both ways
and uh yeah right it could also be
biden's winning by more but
you get a vaccine that starts going to
healthcare workers in october
you get more plasma plasma whatever into
florida florida
all over the place however you pronounce
your a's and trump can take credit for
it
and three becomes 2.2 and that's the
situation in 2016. so
you've got that in addition to this we
now have
reports that claim that the voter
registration numbers now this is this is
how many democrats are registered versus
how many uh republicans are registered
that the numbers of registration in
pennsylvania uh north carolina florida
what was the other state
maybe ohio that republicans have gained
an advantage in terms of the number of
registered voters now
republic there may be more republicans
but they may not vote right
but you you this is what i'm trying to
explain to people
it's there's a too many people that are
of the mindset
that biden's crushing trump and
something major has to happen to reverse
it not really
and in fact let's pull up i think my 10
is an exaggeration if you look at the
real clear politics average
let's look at trump versus biden so look
at this
the average of these polls is biden plus
seven
most of the polls have a margin of error
of 3.5 which applies to each candidate
3.5 doesn't mean
in a poll that's plus seven it's either
plus three point five or plus ten point
five
it's the biden support could be off by
three and a half
and the trump support could be off by
three and a half so biden
averaging plus seven means it could be
tied right now
all right i don't want to belabor this
but but let's let's leave it there so
when people say
dream up a scenario where trump could
win i don't need to
it's just trump could win trump could be
winning right now uh
in some key states and uh we all have to
be
very very careful about that
um we are in the middle of a level five
hype train on twitch
we have three minutes to complete um
level five
and i think uh i think that
it's conceivable conceivable that it
might happen
okay christopher gilliam says whatever
issue causing your feed to die via
mobile app seems specific to your
channel i got reports yesterday that
um a lot of youtube streams were having
problems on mobile
i can assure you it is not on our end
we've checked in with our tech team at
youtube
jacob ball says pacman leading seder 918
to 911
000 team pacman but not unsubbing from
the majority report because why would i
beautiful that's exactly right and i'm
trying to see here we are
at um yeah 918 000 you're you're
exactly right exactly right waffles
giraffe says david you have to read the
manuals read the books yeah
those would tell me that testing is bad
right paul milbank says somebody at
youtube is a die-hard trump supporter
two consecutive days of your stream
crashing that's ugly a retro pathetic
says chess let black move first switch
roles king and queen oh my god
how boring thomas collier says what
makes you think trump would never
go to prison despite all the
investigations into his businesses and
stuff that were before his election
this is not a country that sends former
presidents to prison
i am not giving you my opinion of
whether trump deserves to go to prison
i'm just saying if people are waiting
around for trump to go to prison
i think you're going to be waiting
around for a very long time rc from the
nyc
many people aren't realizing that donald
trump isn't trying to save his
presidency he's trying to save his name
brand right the idea being that
he could lose but say it's rigged and
all of this stuff and kind of try to
save face i don't think that that's
crazy
but trump is very narcissistic i don't
think he can
i think he'll after the fact come up
with some rationalization like that
thanks to calf fly away for the twitch
prime sub
as well as tan man who has gotten us to
a level five hype train completion we've
completed it you don't want to start
tasks and leave them undone and that's
exactly
exactly what just happened let's look at
just maybe like
one clip here this is from fox and
friends this morning i have an entire
segment about this on my youtube channel
right now did that publish
it did so i won't go over all of it but
here is trump given a third attempt at
what do you want to do in your second
term and he still can't answer it he
lists
some races and ethnicities but he still
can't answer the question
mr president what is your second term
agenda what are your top priorities
nasty question i want to take where we
left we had the greatest economy in the
history of the world we were better than
any other country we were better than
we were ever we we never had anything
like it
we were better than we were ever 160
million people working we've never had
that before we've never even come close
now do you guys want me to do the labor
force participation explainer or not
i mean if you guys want me to do it i'll
do it because that was relevant
otherwise i'll just keep going
some people say no some people say yes
no need okay all right fine we'll keep
going say that
best employment numbers best unemployed
for african-american asian-american
women
hispanic everybody the best numbers
we've ever great numbers for hispanic
ever had the best stock market we've
ever had although we're coming very
close right now in fact nasdaq is
already higher than
that numbers that's nasdaq that's two
z's two g's if you're wondering how
that's spelled
nazdag it's a very trump has made that a
very long word
okay here is the labor force
participation uh
trick in short order you might remember
barack obama's president republicans
more people than ever aren't working
today we have a record number of people
not working
trump becomes president first job jobs
report comes out
we have more people than ever working
today how could that when how
huh how could that possibly be here's
the trick the u.s population continues
to grow
if you have unemployment roughly equal
at any given time you can say accurately
more people than ever are working today
and more people than ever are not
working today now of course as baby
boomers retire that
shifts it in one direction you have a
pandemic and you have a lot of
unemployment shifts in a direct
i get that but that's that that's the
trick it's just we have 331 million
people we used to have 320.
now we've got 100 000 more people
working than ever before
and 100 000 people not working and more
people not working than ever it's a
stupid trick it's a very very
dumb trick um
okay we're getting closer to this event
getting started which is uh
very important um okay
a few other people to thank matt heater
is new member number five today at
joinedpakman.com sean coleman
is new member number six ash stevens
is new member number seven today
benjamin hanser and maya weaver
are numbers eight and nine uh and oh i
thanked sean mcinturf
already well you get two thank yous sean
you only count once but you get two
thank yous
um okay my name is jimmy brodigan says
david what do you think about
kanye at this point in the presidential
race is he relevant anymore
no i've i was never talking about kanye
kanye admittedly suffers from bipolar
disorder i think that what we saw from
kanye over the last four
four weeks was essentially an acute
medical event a mental illness event i
don't think it's particularly funny
he seems to be very very ill i don't
think the presidential run is
interesting
i think it's completely uninteresting in
fact and
i really don't have much else to say
about it other than he seems to need
help
that's all i think it's a it's an
episode
neptune says has trump ever done the
dishes david i don't think so i doubt it
i don't think trump has ever done dishes
inedible trout grabbed a membership
azeem abu khalil
says please spread awareness amongst the
public particularly individuals parties
of influence
about the horrific persecution of uyghur
muslims in china yeah we're working on
an interview related to that in fact
jake says is it just me or where did
jake go
is it just me or are there a ridiculous
amount of trump ads on youtube how much
is he spending don jr talking into his
webcam is violently jarring i haven't
seen that
renholder says do you think news
networks will catch on to the fact that
they could have days of election results
coverage instead of just one night
because of malin
you know that's interesting i really
don't um
when trump says we might not know the
results for years that's obviously
idiotic when trump says it might take a
few days to get the results who cares i
want the correct results i'll wait
he's president until january 20th why do
i need them on november 3rd i'll take
the right answer on november 8th it's
not a big deal
not worried about it alex marek says
thoughts on the nevada lawsuit i assume
you mean trump's lawsuit to stop
um expanded vote by uh vote
absentee by mail that's what i'm calling
it i haven't seen the lawsuit
jennifer busato asks what's twitch it's
a totally different platform where
really crazy things happen
very very crazy things happen on twitch
um
i was thinking earlier you know there's
this this entire thing about
vote by mail is bad but absentee is good
and
we're really talking about expanded
absentee access
why we should look at a rebrand on it
and my idea was
universal absentee ballots universe or
univer absentee by mail i'm voting
absentee by mail
to kind of try to defuse this entire
vote by mail
versus absentee thing it's an idea
underscore door says do you think kanye
will have a big impact on the election
no i don't think so unknown prodigy says
i've been listening to trump's insanity
for so long that it's affecting my
judgment when people are making jokes
i have to take a break not sure i know
what you mean
thanks to bookmd for the subscription
baron steuben says tell pat
i say hi all right i will
sharknado herbo says watch you every day
how is iowa doing on covid
i don't know uh let's let's take a look
iowa where is iowa here it is
um under a thousand deaths seems to be
sort of linear growth they've been
essentially in a holding pattern
for three and a half months so it's
getting slightly worse let's look at a
moving average
the moving average has been worsening so
it seems iowa basically improved from
about may 8th
until june 19th and then much like many
other states from june 19th until now
it's been getting worse in terms of
deaths
death's starting to spike around july 6.
it's the exact same pattern we've seen
in many states which is cases start to
go up
in mid to late june and then deaths
start to go up
right around between july 8th and 10th
it's the exact same pattern
that we've seen in a whole bunch of
different states
satu gustafson says so scared and don't
even live in the united states
remember the sorry everybody website in
2004
if you botch this in november you so
need to recreate that yeah i have a
story that i
um put together for tomorrow's show
called
we owe the world an apology and an
explanation
i think you can probably infer the gist
of that story
and um i will uh tell you more about
that tomorrow
people asking if there's a chess stream
today yeah so after this stream i'm
going to be doing a twitch only stream
continuing my preparation and that's a
term i'm using very loosely
continuing my preparation for
chess.com's pogchamps 2 tournament
today i will be with alexandra botez
and tomorrow if you missed my
lesson with uh grand master hikaru
nakamura
that will be published in full to
youtube tomorrow
and then tonight it will be
live with alexander botez and that will
then be published to youtube
maybe friday or something like that
so uh yeah
okay what else do we have bolo turner
says
am i a bot i hope not alex walker says
what does a lame duck trump look like
considering there's no more need to
pander to his base
there's two possibilities outrageously
unhinged
or recedes into even more tv watching at
the white house doesn't even leave the
residence
and recedes into irrelevance and i don't
think we'll know
first let's see if he loses then we'll
figure out what he's going to do
neptune says sam cedar won't win he
grows
slow like the cedar tree clever
maggie lee preston says hey love the
show i want to learn a little more about
political analysis what would you
recommend in terms of books or resources
that's so tough i mean there's just so
much i'm not the right person to ask
um i would i would do a google search i
think that's the way to go
i do want to mention that uh this month
is the 15-year
anniversary of the david pakman show it
will mark 15 years
of programming now of course a lot of
that time
i was still in school and it was sort of
like an afterthought i would show up
every two weeks and talk for an hour
but but um it is still very exciting
and i am hoping that we will bring in
the
largest number of new members in a
single month this month so consider
yourself invited to go to my website
joinpakman.com grab a membership
membership is the primary
source for funding our operations
connectivity
equipment new microphones like this
beautiful specimen
uh you know employee benefits and health
insurance and all of this stuff so for
example
pamela cameron just became a member and
she's new member number 10.
cam roy is new member number 11.
you can sign up at joinpackman.com it's
quick
it feels good the website works
beautifully and you don't even have to
pay full price
because you can use this coupon code
2020 now what's better
than getting 66 off but getting all of
the benefits
you get all of them and when does your
price go up
never we don't do low low introductory
price
we don't do pay-only shipping and
handling i don't do any of that crap
okay you get the discount you pay a
dollar 83 a month
if you pay yearly uh or two bucks a
month if you pay monthly
that's your price for as long as you
want to keep it you want to then upgrade
because financial circumstances improve
have at it right nobody's going to stop
you
but there's no low low introductory
price stuff i hate that stuff okay
that's the price and um i will continue
thanking folks
who sign up um when is this starting
your guest is as good as mine scheduled
for 10 minutes ago
we know that they are very very late all
the time
um thanks to cappinator aka cappy
for subscribing on twitch as well as
music man
snuffalo bill harvey bolivari
weddletime e1 and a whole bunch of other
people
i saw an interesting super chat i just
want to look at this for a second
yet mo lester okay mo lester great you
got me
there's a fascinating reddit thread
delving into the difference between your
twitch and youtube persona is it tiring
playing different characters
i want to see that can somebody tell me
where to find that is that on my
subreddit because that actually sounds
super compelling let me see here
um oh i don't see that
is it an old thread because i'm looking
at the latest page of threads
and i don't see that about different
personas
if somebody can email that to me or tell
me how to find it that would actually be
really funny
i would be curious to see what people
are saying about that
okay let me go back up um
where were we
okay joel says if you do something about
uyghurs in china look
whom paid for the report and biases
also put in correlation
to what u.s have done against uyghur's
disinfo okay
legion says
translated that means hey david i love
your program and everything you do
continue with the good work appreciate
that spanish super chat's always welcome
johnny minogue says did you hear rhode
island is now on the massachusetts
travel restricted states
this is having me concerned about
another massachusetts shutdown coming
soon
well listen charlie baker uh should have
shut down indoor dining here weeks ago
we are headed in the wrong direction
hundreds of new cases let's actually
look
at where the data is data and data i
like both of them
so where is massachusetts here
uh okay here we are we had this
look at this oh my god we crushed the
curve and then this is a slow burn
but we're starting to see the numbers
climb we were down to you know 200 cases
a day
in this area we started hitting 230 250
280 300
400 we've got to shut it down and
our active cases were down and then now
they're coming back up
uh deaths are not yet back up but that's
because there's about a 20-day lag
so um i don't like it i don't like it
and i think we need to shut it down
right away
right away um neptune says can you
stream a video game maybe sonic
i mean listen i'm streaming chess later
but
that's worldometers.info people asking
about that website
i once i did a stream of me doing a
speed run of super mario world
and i i never did it again because i was
ridiculed too much
unknown prodigy says do you know what
the chess lesson is on tonight no i mean
i think it's just a way for me not to
get embarrassed during pogchamps too
that's what that's the focus
walla is me says nearly 920
000 subscribers nice thanks for making
these bearable
yeah let's see we are at 9 18
and a half in fact we have 6 000 people
watching on youtube right now
assuming a bunch of you are already
subscribers even if like half of you hit
the sign up button right now
which is free subscribe we could get to
9 20. we're in a race to a million and i
think we're to do very very well
extremely well it's going to be
something nobody has ever seen before
donna williams says can trump be stopped
from giving his speech at the white
house i assume you mean the rnc
speech no he probably can't be stopped
unfortunately morton nilsson says
stalling video can be fixed by lowering
resolution
you're talking about kind of two
different things there morton the
problem yesterday with the youtube
stream was that something was wrong with
youtube mobile
and um it's that that's a dif
you're saying if somebody watching has a
slow connection and you're right
but yesterday's problem was it was a
different one
essential says where to watch first year
pacman streams
on youtube you can just go all the way
back to the beginning and find
my youtube videos from 2009. it's a
little bit cringe i'm not going to lie
but they are there
eric dahlin asks do you think trump will
have the hbo interview on his mind
during this press conference well
he did a press conference yesterday i
don't know if that was on his mind
shannon clark has signed up waffles
giroffels
says tell botez that the sm-7b is a top
address mic i don't even know what that
means
garrison spangler and desiree have
grabbed and upgraded subscriptions
underscore door says i'm in new zealand
just had a drop in unemployment
do you think the press needs to bring
unemployment comparisons to light i hear
people compare
our coveted reaction to the usa but the
after effects seem more relevant yeah
the economic impacts are related to the
way you deal with the virus
and part of why the american economy
won't recover for a long time is because
we've dealt with the virus so poorly i
mean
it's an unmitigated disaster here and i
i know that people like kaylee mckennany
and trump and others keep saying we're
doing well
you you would have to be willfully
ignorant or or delusional
um or just unable to understand anything
to think that the united states has done
a good job it's
there's not even any argument thanks to
truth seeker and
imaudi00325 for the subscriptions i
appreciate that
amy gray says i would pay money for a
member of the press to ask trump why are
you always late that way i would love
that
i would love that dave wampler
asks is the axios interview trump's
lowest point
point among none non-cult i don't know
the answer to that
it was a very low point it was a very
low point
master mcclevy over on twitch has
subscribed and says happy to be here for
six months david i'm happy you've been
here for six months
thanks to baby love number one night
tour and
darth snoosh for subscribing on twitch
as well
appreciate that simp king
1576 says what if coronavirus gets to
the point
the best way to stop the spread is to
kill the host of the virus like anyone
who has the virus
that's completely idiotic and even if
you thought that morally it was
acceptable
in the process of doing so more people
would catch it and you'd have to kill
more and more people i assume that
that's a complete and total joke if not
uh please please seek help betty
gibson is new member number 12 today at
joinedpakman.com
blake bender and john townsend are new
members number 13 and 14
joe maldonado and dylan moss our new
members number 15 and 16.
laura duff pastor bob heigl
anthony sanchez robert zimmer
our new members 17 18 19 and 20.
at joinpackman.com that's a beautiful
number
um you have not missed anything if
you're just joining us trump's just
running late again
the running late has almost become a
parody of itself at this point i mean
it's just complete and total disrespect
for everybody which is the name of the
game for this administration
that's ghastly said is there any credit
to claims that they're counting deaths
not actually caused by kovid there is
not
here is donald trump we're going to go
over to the
uh white house feed i find this feed to
be a better feed
it'll be about 20 seconds delayed but
we'll all be better in the long run for
it moving slowly and gingerly today and
almost dragging that right foot that's
weird thank you very much everybody
it's good to be with you i'd like to
begin by
providing an update on my
administration's actions
to protect american workers as we battle
the china virus
since the virus escaped china
my administration has enacted three
trillion dollars in economic relief
it's been very very successful and you
saw that by the numbers that were issued
yesterday and the day before as to used
car
sales and auto production they've been
incredible numbers actually
shockingly incredible we've been
negotiating
in good faith with democrat leaders in
the house
to extend relief payments we're
negotiating
right now as we speak and we'll see how
that works out but
if democrat leaders put partisan demands
aside
we would reach an agreement very quickly
if he happened
it would happen very quickly in the
meantime my administration is exploring
executive actions to provide protections
against eviction
eviction is a big problem very unfair to
a lot of people it wasn't their fault
that this
virus came from a far away land
as well as additional relief to those
who are
unemployed as a result of the virus very
importantly i'm
also looking at a term limited
suspension of the payroll tax hmm
something that has great support from
many many sides especially
unclear if he can do that legally
economists
and some people that we have great
respect for
so we're looking at a suspension of the
payroll tax
the democrats are primarily interested
in a
1 trillion dollar bailout of the
poorly run states we have some states
and cities you know them all we don't
have to go through names but
the states that are poorly run and
economically not viable are mostly red
states i hope you all know that we're
not going to go along with that
especially since it's not covid related
earlier today i met with a great
governor
arizona governor oh god doug ducey has
really done a fantastic job
terrible job beyond even the covid
situation which you've been reading
about
as it pertains to arizona
a state that is a model for applying a
science-based approach to the
decreasing cases and hospitalizations
without implementing
a punishing lockdown that's the wrong
arizona's record in
reducing the spread of the virus while
maintaining hospital capacity
and allowing society to continue
functioning and functioning very nicely
it's almost like what he says has no
connection to reality
there's an example that shows how our
path forward can work in other states
arizona has a record and
a record really to be proud of it's
reduced the number of daily new cases by
over 75 percent cut the positivity rate
in half and reduced
er visits by two-thirds all
the while keeping the economy
functioning and functioning
really well when cases i have friends in
arizona every single one says it's an
unmitigated disaster
visited arizona to consult with governor
ducey they had
long consultations with governor ducey
and his staff
and the vice president has been in
constant contact ever since
my administration is also collaborating
with the state and local officials
across the south and midwest i encourage
people to check out the youtube video
from an
mit class um called how to speak
this is breaking essentially every rule
for how to do powerpoint slides like
it's a excellent video i recommend it
million
pieces of personal patrick winston i
believe is the professor sadly passed
away
how to speak excellent excellent mit
class
we've provided over one excuse me
we provided over 18 billion dollars in
economic support to arizona including
more than 8.6 billion dollars to support
over
80 000 small businesses so we really
have been helping arizona and it's
gotten tremendous results
our goal is to protect the most
vulnerable
increase recovery rates you know that
something so important and prevent
hospital overcrowding
all the while avoiding the kind of
stringent lockdowns that would inflict
substantial suffering
in the phase and this phase of the
battle
we have the tools resources and
knowledge to implement a targeted
approach
as we race to deliver a vaccine
and we are really uh working very hard
on the vaccine and we're doing i think
they're doing a fantastic
job i've been meeting with officials of
some of the greatest companies in the
world
meeting with scientists and they're
getting uh they're getting very close
if not there they're getting very close
they're testing
any proper analysis of infection control
measures must take into account the
short-term and long-term public health
harms
including death caused by a far-reaching
shutdown when you shut down
you have many many things that happen
from suicides to
depression to drinking alcohol problems
to
drug problems the problems with
marriages
problems with marriages trump wants to
save your marriage by sending your kids
to school
their house their apartment for long
periods of time maybe bring back the
virus to your house
also instead arizona's adopted the
following measures the governor advised
residents to aggressively social
distance when possible and maintain
strict hygiene
the state encouraged mass use in crowded
public space
places especially when social distancing
is not possible the governor also
exercised his discretion to
restrict capacity at indoor locations to
limit the possibility of
super spreading it's a big thing my
administration
surged treatments we got them a lot of
treatments
and therapies to the state including
nearly 70
000 vials of remdi severe enough to
treat over 11
000 patients and it's been very
successful i might day
my administration also delivered ppe and
point of care testing to over 100
arizona nursing homes in total the
federal government has provided
massive amounts of masks and equipments
and gowns and
you know some of those numbers but
arizona was a very big
beneficiary and they very much received
were very much really
appreciated more than 1 000 national
guard and medical personnel have also
been deployed in arizona and they've
really helped
they've been terrific and i want to
thank them
they have been brave and brilliant
combination of both we also supported
our tribal communities the tribal
communities were hit very very hard
governor ducey and i personally
delivered rapid testing systems anybody
know why the focus is only on arizona
today any idea
it's been really really
in originally bad shape and now getting
better and
very very quickly the navajo nation now
has one of the highest levels of testing
per capita anywhere in the world
we really worked very hard on the tribal
areas
and in particular in this case the
navajo nation they've done
incredibly well overall arizona has
conducted over 1.1 million tests
more than the entire nations of japan
mexico and switzerland
arizona's per capita testing is higher
than germany
south korea france and canada and tribal
governments in arizona have received
nearly 1.3 billion dollars for the
coronavirus relief fund meanwhile
outdoor dining limited
indoor dining and most of the other
businesses in arizona have remained open
and very vibrant they're doing
incredibly well
this is an approach and it's an approach
that's been
incredibly successful arizona's been
able to protect high-risk populations
and quickly bring
its outbreak under control without the
need to impose
overly punitive measures thanks to
advances in treating the virus the
fatality rate
across all age groups in arizona is
very low arizona scientific and data
driven
strategy also preserved hospital
capacity
ensuring that those who need care were
able to receive it and receive it
immediately very quickly
at the peak approximately 15 percent of
beds remained available statewide that
was at their peak
with roughly 20 of all occupied beds
going to patients hospitalized for the
virus
they kept other things going they kept
other forms of
operations going they kept elective
surgery going
did a really amazing job today only six
percent of the current hospitalizations
in the state
are related to the china virus arizona
has also
demonstrated success in protecting the
state's african-american population
only five percent of patients
hospitalized were african-american and
americans represent this is just two
percent of all deaths from the virus
as it has worked to contain its outbreak
arizona has also been formulating a plan
to get children
safely back to school as soon as
possible we want our schools open
all over the country we want our schools
open arizona's work
check out how that went in georgia very
well the department of education
is providing arizona schools with 625
million dollars they're working very
hard
and that's in conjunction with cares
funding
my administration is actively working
with other states in the same way we
worked with arizona
in recent weeks members of the corona
virus task force have visited
over 15 states to encourage them to
follow our path forward including
tennessee
kentucky virginia indiana and ohio
and i'll be going to ohio tomorrow i
look forward to it very much
it's a great place and a great state
with an excellent governor
and we look forward to being there
tomorrow next week dr burke
we'll be visiting iowa nebraska kansas
missouri oklahoma and arkansas
and also i believe they're trying to get
in west virginia a great place a great
state and i'm something better than this
flying off i would like it to happen
they'd like to see her
so we're going to try very hard to get
the doctor to west virginia in addition
to those states to deliver aggressive
tailored and targeted guidance
the strategy we're taking to these
states
will protect those at highest risk while
allowing others
at a lower risk to safely resume work in
school if
we do this successfully it can be really
something
incredible because we're talking about a
lot of states we're talking about many
many states
it's really great to see also that
florida we're coming down it's coming
down
and pretty substantially in many levels
remember florida stopped testing on
thursday because of the hurricane
they've not they were supposed to resume
today
in california likewise in texas like
california also admitted that they've
been under reporting cases
it's this is this is lunacy reduction
it recognizes that prolonged lockdowns
impose a wide range of serious
public health threats including higher
levels of suicide
drug overdoses and other significant
health harms resulting from
the depression that we talked about
social isolation economic hardship
it's been very tough for those people
that are
put in a lockdown position for too long
really has been a very tough and harmful
situation for many people the fact is
that these harms are
not measured daily here or abroad it
makes them
really a very serious threat because
people don't know exactly what they are
and how bad they are but i think they're
very bad going forward you must continue
to remain vigilant in shielding of the
elderly
and those with underlying conditions
approximately half of all deaths
have occurred in nursing homes and
long-term care facilities which is an
incredible
number and statistic if you think about
it
i also urge americans to help us stop
the spread of the virus
practice good hygiene socially distance
avoid large crowds and wear a mask where
distancing is not
possible it's a patriotic thing to do
if you are sick isolate yourself
especially from high risk family members
and friends so important
isolate yourself from high risk
family members and friends if you're not
feeling well
together we will defeat the virus and
emerge from this safer and stronger than
ever
thanks to the robust federal action and
partnership with state and local leaders
new cases of the virus are
declining in 80 percent of the
jurisdictions which is an incredible
number
yesterday it was 70 and we still don't
know what they mean by jurisdictions
since since last week zero states have
seen outbreaks get worse since yesterday
so
zero states since yesterday what
how is that even relevant statistically
the development of a vaccine
this is something so important also
therapeutics are
on the front burner we're having
tremendous i
think we'll let you know very soon i
think long before the end of the year
we're having tremendous success on
therapeutics and tremendous success on
vaccines and we're ready to deliver them
literally as soon as they're okay this
morning my administration approved one
billion dollars for johnson and johnson
who's
been working very hard can in something
very special
to manufacture and distribute 100
million doses of a china virus vaccine
as soon as
one is about a virus vaccine and again
we think that's going to be soon and we
think we're going to
china is going to end up having like the
first you know really solid vaccine the
way things are
are going uh just you know in terms of
the way it's been going could happen and
then trump's gonna have to end up
getting a china virus vaccine from china
nationwide providing assistance to
human trafficking victims a terrible
thing you think of human trafficking as
being an ancient
form of crime it's not because of the
internet it's a very modern crime all
over the world
not just here all over the world human
trafficking it's usually in women
or women and children but it's again
because of the internet
it's a terrible situation never been
like this
and also survivors who face heightened
dangers during the pandemic
it's actually increased during the
pandemic
uh i guess some reasons are obvious and
some reasons are less obvious but human
trafficking we're working
very very strongly the wall is up to 200
277 miles right now
wait so is the wall working and fewer
people than ever are coming over or is
human trafficking up as he says how is
it both and it's had a tremendous impact
a very positive impact on human
trafficking unbelievable impact actually
my administration will never rest in our
fight i mean trafficking is way up but
the walls had a huge impact on it okay
horrific of crimes and we work very hard
on that
with that we'll take some questions
please two quick questions thank you mr
president first of all
you said that voting by mail is an
invitation to fraud
could you lay out and tell us exactly
where the evidence is right now that
mail-in ballots in nevada and other
states
will leave i'll mention something about
new york having to redo an election even
the washington post had a terrible story
on
uh mail-in and the new york times and
many uh
many newspapers have had terrible
stories you see them all over the
internet they've had some just
horrible stories on mail-in ballots
you look at arizona you don't even have
to have as you know they have a
provision where they don't have to check
signatures so you sign it and you could
have a totally different signature it's
okay
it won't be approved they have the right
to go seven days after the election for
approval so you're not even going to
know who won the state of nevada
well i just want to point out we did
call nevada's secretary of state's
office election division and the
spokeswoman there said that that
simply isn't true mr president that
nevada will continue to check ballot
signatures against voter registration
cards
it's done at the county level okay but
that's not what they said when they
approved it they said they're not going
to check signatures they're not going to
be able to
and their machinery which is old doesn't
allow them to so they're going to be
it's going to be physically impossible
for them to do that
especially in a short period of time in
addition you have the november third
election
and they're allowed to count votes until
seven days a year so we know on november
10 maybe okay what's the big deal
it may not even be that close by the way
batter which is a big state and a great
state a state i like very much and i
think we're going to do very well there
this isn't going to come down to nevada
after november 3rd
if it comes down to nevada which it
could very well it won't
i don't think so i don't think it's
appropriate trump's worried about not
knowing by november 10th yet he's
floating the idea of delaying the
election
with the harvesting you're going to have
with people being sent ballots
all over that that have maybe nothing to
do with the state anymore
it's a terrible thing in new york they
had the carolyn
maloney situation and i criticized it
badly over the last two years in
two days i mean i gave it to some very
very strong criticism
and all of a sudden like a miracle they
just approved the winner well what
happened did the
person that was second concede the race
even though it was
very close and all mixed up they have a
terrible situation in new york with the
ballots you know that
and as soon as i said well i think you
should have a new election because the
election obviously they're not going to
know what to do i think you should have
a new election
they all of a sudden announced a winner
i assume it was her but they announced a
winner crystal clear well i don't agree
with it did somebody speak to the person
on the other side the opponent did they
do something for the opponent on the
other side take a look at patterson
these are wild unfounded conspiracies
he's asserting here going on with the
melon ballots they send out millions of
ballots
millions of ballots they're totally
unprepared to do it and then they come
back in the millions
uh it's going to be a disaster i'm doing
our country a big favor oh yeah bringing
it up and you know from a couple you
should be thanking this guy
common sense standpoint if you look at
it just
out of common sense and pure
basic beautiful intelligence you know it
can't work
now florida's worked very hard for years
and years and developing a system
i'm sure they probably have problems
what about the states that are just all
vote by mail and have been for years
mail-in ballots what you call universal
mail-in ballots so much different you
have to apply for it you have to do
different things and it's a much better
system and it's a system that can be
reasonably accurate
wacky but there's no system like going
to the poll
and voting so i would like to find out
why all of a sudden out of nowhere in
the midst of all of this grief
why is it that they approved the new
york race
while you asked that question right sir
there's no evidence of widespread voter
product
oh really well then you're reading then
you're reading a different newspaper
than me a delay doesn't mean that
there's fraud
go ahead please go sir uh you said an
interview this morning on the corona
virus this thing's going away
it will go away like things go away
despite ongoing cases
isn't that true it's going away now
it'll go away like things go away
absolutely eventually he'll give you a
question in my mind it will go away
a year and a half hopefully sooner
rather than later
mr president we praise governor ducey's
handling of the
of the epidemic in his state one of the
things that he did was delay the start
of public schools opening is that a
model that uh governors and states
experiencing hot spots
should uh should close maybe maybe
school does it well i'd like to see the
schools open
i think many of the schools most of the
schools will be open i can say that
republican areas want to see them open
and the democrats probably want to keep
them closed until
after november third person they think
it's good for them politically i
actually
don't think it's good for them
politically parents want the schools
open we want them open we want them open
safely we're going to practice very
strong hygiene and all of the other
things that i've
enumerated many times but we want to see
the schools open
here and what part of that model was his
model i just think he's done a very good
job i mean he's really done a great job
income here numbers you look at how it's
dropped and very rapidly he's done a
great job he's a great governor please
interview this morning mr president you
were talking about opening the schools
and you said children
are virtually immune from coven 19 but
children have contracted this virus and
someone died
i'm talking about from getting very sick
if you look at children i mean they're
able to throw it off very easily
and it's an amazing thing because some
flus they don't they get very sick and
they have problems with flus and they
have problems with other things but
for whatever reason the china virus
children handle it very well
i know and they may they may get it but
they get it and it
it doesn't have much of an impact on
them and if you look at the numbers the
numbers of
of in terms of mortality fatality the
numbers for children
under a certain age meaning young their
immune systems are very very strong
they're very powerful
and they they seem to be able to handle
it very well and that's according to
every
statistic mr president at least two
people connected to kanye west's effort
to get on the ballot have been connected
to the republican party
is this kanye west he's getting on the
ballot including at swing states and as
you know his wife
has raised issues about whether he's
having mental issues right now so my
question to you is
are you aware of or have you encouraged
anyone in the party to help him get on
the ballot including
no not at all no not at all other than i
get along with him very well i like him
i like his wife
his wife recommended certain people as
you know
for including alice johnson who's a
fantastic woman but his wife recommended
certain people
to get out of prison they were in prison
for
a long time a long long time
that should have never happened and i
took what she said very strong
kim kim kardashian yep kim and uh he's
got a good heart very good heart
and uh i like kanye's history i have
nothing to do with him getting on the
bill
we'll have to see what happens we'll see
if he gets on the belt but i'm not
involved
thank you mr president i wanted to ask
you the group of republican senators are
backing 25 billion dollars
in payroll assistance to keep the
airlines uh
uh being able to pay their payrolls do
you
and you know to endorse that
another 25 billion dollars for airline
airlines to keep their payrolls going
well if they need it certainly that's a
business some businesses are doing
better than they would normally
obviously we know what those businesses
are and
obviously the airline business is not
doing very well you have
shutdowns all over the world and you
have airlines that are essentially shut
down
some airlines are doing you know modest
best of doing is modest
i think it's very important that we keep
the airlines going they'll be
very good times very soon i hope and we
don't want to lose our airlines so
if they're looking at that whether
they're republican or democrat i'd be
certainly in favor we can't lose our
transportation system yes go ahead i'm
going to ask you two on beirut so
there's been some
question about your comments yesterday
yes saying that it was
an attack and that you'd heard from
military officials
that there was uh you know an explosion
that it looked like something sort
i can tell you whatever happened it's
terrible but they don't really know what
it is nobody knows yet
uh at this moment they're looking it
could i mean how can you say accident
somebody was
you know left some terrible
explosive type devices and things around
perhaps
perhaps it was that device it was an
attack i don't think anybody can say
right now we're looking into it very
strongly right now it's uh
i mean you have some people think it was
an attack and you some people that think
it wasn't that's not what's being in any
event it was a terrible event and a lot
of people
were doubling down tremendous number of
people wounded
injured and uh we're standing with
with that country you know we have a
very good relationship with that country
but it's a country
what's it called against a lot of
turmoil a lot of problems
but we stand with them
thank you you said earlier today that
you are considering using the white
house as the venue for your nomination
speech
um senator john thune questioned whether
or not that's actually legal given the
hatch act
is this something that you would get
clearance for john did
right the republican jonathan oh okay
well it is legal uh there is no hatch
act because it doesn't pertain to the
president
but if i use the white house we save
tremendous amounts of money for the
government
in terms of security traveling if we go
to another state or something he golfed
284 days and he says i should do us
a campaign speech at the white house to
save the taxpayers money 284 days he's
golfed so far
it would be by far the least expensive
location right very little
very concerned about the cost yeah
tremendous traveling security with
airplanes and everybody flying all over
the place
flying all over it i think it would be a
very convenient idea it's something that
we
i hope nobody's dumb enough to fall for
this just by comparison to any other
location yeah please
yeah um your son don jr tweeted
yesterday asking you to direct the epa
to reject the pebble mine in bristol bay
alaska it's a giant copper and gold mine
and uh the thinking is injected in what
way
right just reject its construction the
the army corps of engineers
two weeks ago suggested it'd be okay to
proceed with the project but it would
sportsmen like your son are saying that
it would be harmful
well i've listened to god don jr is not
a sportsman he paid to kill an elephant
you know and a sportsman like his son
opinions and he is very much of an
environmentalist and he was very
impressed with what we did yesterday
because that's one of the great
environmental bills and beyond that ever
signed since
since uh well i guess over 100 years if
you think about it it's been a long time
but uh i will look at both sides of it i
had heard about it
uh i will be i understand they're going
to be doing a briefing sometime
over the next 48 hours you're going to
go very quickly i've done a lot for
alaska i love alaska it's a special
place
anwar was one thing uh the highway cove
highway
or whatever the new name is whatever the
old name is whatever
we're getting approvals for a tremendous
highway that's been sought for
40 years they've been trying to get
environmentalists sportsman don jr
uh we've done a lot for alaska it's a
special place
and i'll take a look at that it's
interesting yeah please guys
thank you mr president two brief
questions first
your administration has praised
ambulance drivers
and the ambulance service for that i
love this guy in dealing with the
corolla
virus and recently there has been
scuttlebutt
that ambulance associations
drivers and all have not been fully
reimbursed for the work they're doing
they said they are old 2.8 that mass
cannot contain this guy's face
and they've only received 300 million
from the provider relief
not 300 billion 300. give me 300 million
at the provider relief fund at hhs
are you going to look into this or i
just heard of it for the first time
the ambulance people have done an
incredible job
as the doctors the nurses the frontline
workers
law enforcement has been incredible the
military
fema i mean i could name almost every
group i can't most powerful man in the
world folks
but the ambulance people have done a
very it's a tough job too very dangerous
job very tough job
uh i will certainly look in i mean
you're telling me something that for the
first time
nobody is complaining about not getting
paid too much
but we'll take a look at the ambulance
drivers the other thing
secretary esper said today
that based on what he had heard
the incident in beirut he felt was
an accident now he's disagreed with you
on other things before
do you have any comment about his
remarks whatever he uh
if he if that's what he heard i think
that i've heard it both ways too
i've heard accent i've heard you know
explosives and
obviously it must have been some form of
explosives but whether it was a bomb
intentionally set off it ended up being
a bomb
but no i've heard it both ways it could
have been an accident and it could have
also been something that was very
offensive and uh i wouldn't be very
happy with that
and you have no problem just to follow
up on that even if you just have
suspicion that the beirut explosion
is a bomb do you have any plans of
pertaining to u.s assets in the region
for example i mean how are you
great we're working very closely with
the government and we're working very
closely with many different agencies
including the military
and we'll be able to figure it out we
already probably have figured it out
thank you very much everybody
he's got to get out before someone says
mr president do you know what country
beirut is in uh and having to get out
quick quick quick quick before that uh
that question comes up
um wow these i don't know that he should
really be doing these anymore right i
mean it doesn't it doesn't
seem like it's helping anything and i
think every time he has a bad interview
like the axios fiasco he's like okay let
me do something
i'll call into fox and friends this
morning and then
as we looked at earlier that went
totally wrong so then it's like let me
go out and read some stuff about how
great arizona is and answer
he can't stop himself i think that it is
time to cancel these again
uh if you're heading out on youtube
please do me a very small favor
hit that subscribe button we're trying
to get to a million subscribers by
election day if just a hundred of you do
it we'll be at 9
19 we're at 9 18 right now we'll get to
9
19 so please consider doing that if
you're over on twitch i'll be back
very very soon with a new stream
and i look forward to seeing everybody
probably in 25 or 30 minutes or so
at uh twitch.tv david pakman
you